also leute hier haben wir einmal das
auto also da werden wirklich
kindheitserinnerungen geweckt früher
hätte ich mich da so darüber gefreut
jung muss gegen diese gegen das
verfahren
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei anderen video leute ich
hoffe natürlich euch jetzt wo gestern
muss sich die alex leavitt woche ja
leider einmal pausieren
als das video von gestern noch nicht
gesehen haben uns auch cool geworden
ansonsten an die die von der alex
leavitt woche noch nicht mitbekommen
haben jeden tag kommt ein video die
ganze woche lang wir haben schon fünf
gemacht oder so checkt die auf jeden
fall nach diesem video ab heute wird's
mal wieder richtig cool ich habe richtig
bock und schlimmer gespannt was war denn
ich habe es noch nicht ganz ausgemacht
das machen einfach mal direkt made in
china stellt schon mal direkt hier dran
leute ich habe dieses ferngesteuerte
auto gesehen und ich habe es direkt
bestellt es hat mich glaube ich 19 euro
gekostet also echt nicht viel bevor es
losgeht wir haben hier dieses schöne
produkt da denke ich wie immer auf den
100 euro gutschein drauf ihr müsst
einfach einen kommentar schreiben und
main kanal abonnieren dann übrigens an
ein paar tausend abonnenten und dann
verlor sich diese beiden sachen also das
produkt und den gutschein unter allen
teilen der mann am 25 dezember wird das
mit aufgelöst also nicht auf jeden fall
teil und wir machen uns jetzt mal ans
auspacken
was hier auch noch dazu sagen muss ich
war früher wirklich ein richtiger fan
von so ferngesteuerten autos und ich
meine so was hat damals in deutschland
wenn man es im spielwarengeschäft
gekauft hat sofort zehn jahren bestimmt
60 70 euro gekostet da gab es zwar auch
noch keinen beweis
aber es ist schon ein unterschied hier
ist auch noch überall verpackten blöd
also leute hier haben wir einmal das
auto also da wären wirklich kinder ist
erinnerung geweckt früher hätte ich mich
da so darüber gefreut das design gefällt
mir auch hier mit dem totenkopf und so
also wirklich ein forsches auto das hier
sind diese typischen fernbedienungen wie
man sie von früher kennt also davon
hatte ich auch viele ich hatte früher
ein schwarzes rennauto das ging richtig
ab damit wollte ich auch immer auch so
kleine strecken fahren falls ihr die
kennt man so rennen gefahren ist gegen
andere leute die autos hatten ich weiß
gar nicht ob dieses auto überhaupt
nirgendwo existiert ich habe es
jedenfalls schon länger nicht mehr
gesehen also auto ist ausgepackt
auch ich habe früher auch so aus da
haben die reichen so fällt das konnte so
fahren und so kennedy jetzt müssen wir
natürlich batterien rein und hier auch
die sind leider nicht dabei aber das
kenne ich ja schon
also machen wir kurz ich würde mich
jetzt richtig freuen wenn dieser
schraubenzieher passt und wer passt da
gibt's in die fernsteuerungen müssen
gleich drei batterien also stromsparen
ist hat auf jeden fall nicht glauben wir
dass hier auch noch eben auch hier sind
sogar schon batterien mit drin
die muss man jetzt hier nur anschließen
ja das ging ja schnell leute bevor ich
das jetzt es ganz wichtig erkennst wir
schauen uns erst mal ein paar rezension
also beides installiert erst mal ein
paar rezensionen was das teil dann so
kann und dann gehen noch mal auf die
strecke während hinter mir gerade ein
parcours aufgebaut wird schauen wir uns
das produkt einmal genauer an so hier
haben wir das auto 20 euro gekostet ich
wusste es nicht mal ganz genau wird auch
wirklich schon sehr oft bestellt wir
haben 2677 bewertungen in zusammen
viereinhalb sterne jeder thomas schreibt
ob mein sohn hat richtig spaß damit
christina ist auch echt begeistert
genial rothacker erhalten funktioniert
super die enkel sind begeistert tolles
auto verpackung beschädigt ja das war
mir auch ganz leicht aber
ein gut solange das auto fährt kam
schneller als erwartet funktioniert
einwandfrei superflitzer
ich kann nur dazu also ich kann dem
eigentlich auch noch hinzufügen
bis jetzt bin ich begeistert so ist das
produkt hwp kann ich jetzt überhaupt
nichts mit anfangen aber gut der versand
hat noch mal extra 10 euro gekostet gibt
es halt auch noch in rot und blau
ich hab's ja ein grün gewählt und ich
glaube der rest des selbst erklären was
will man hat doch wohl sagen
deswegen will ich gar nicht langsam an
wir testen das jetzt einfach mal und ich
bin auch mal gespannt wie schnell das
fertig wird mal schätzen so 10 km h drin
sein wird das ist der parcours ja und so
einen islam der als chemie oder im
parcours kurz also hier jetzt los bei
dem stuhl hier eintragen
ok und das war es also wird erst mal
kurz im parcours dann gehen wir noch
schnell nach draußen und guck mal wie
schnell das pferd ob der unfall sicher
ist okay alles am ende fahren wir noch
dagegen und schauen was passiert haben
wir einfach gegeneinander fahren wer
schneller schafft ja mehr zeit stammen
auch plätze fertig los
[Musik]
er ist ein gepard seine kappe
ja
30 sekunden
ok jetzt bist du so also ich hab 39
sekunden braucht jetzt ist mein kollege
dran
mal gucken wie lange er braucht auf die
plätze fertig los geht's los
oder hat probleme
ja ja ja kommen lassen
irgendwie muss gegen diese gegen das
verfahren
also wir sind jetzt hier schon mal sechs
millisekunden
ok ich glaube dass auch er hat
aufgegeben
leute wir sehen uns jetzt noch mal kurz
raus der fall noch einmal draußen geht
man sprit
doch nicht mehr lange
heute eben schneller
alex und freunde gefunden
wollt ihr eure fußballmannschaft grüßen
ja die großen an training größten geht
also land jetzt haben wir gerade noch
zuschauer getroffen schöne grüße also
ich habe gehofft dass autofahrer ein
bisschen schneller macht aber trotzdem
spaß ist das für mich auch nicht ganz
aufgeladen das war's mit dem video
wenn ihr gewinnen wollt lassen häufig
angerufen lassen kommentar da abonniert
den kanal und brauereien wir sehen uns
morgen wieder